hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Game of Thrones episode 2
video generally I think this episode is
a lot more fun than episode 1 but we're
finally getting into some of the action
of the season we get to see 2 big new
locations we also get to see some really
fun familiar faces careful for spoilers
for the episode if you haven't seen it
yet and new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's for an HBO now subscription
so here we go starting with top five
moments number 5 Arya goes to the house
of black and white if you remember the
last time we saw the Titan of Braavos it
was when Stannis was going to get money
from the iron bank I love how she laughs
at the myth of the Titan you can tell
that she doesn't care about bathe she's
not a religious person I'll be
interested to see how that changes or if
that changes during her time with the
faceless men
I think they redid some of the CG for
the city to the city shots I mean
obviously we moved through the camera we
moved through the city so we see a
couple of different districts but the
big wide CG shot just seems a lot nicer
than the one during season 4 that we saw
there's only 10 episodes this season so
III do think that there are a lot of
places in Braavos that we just won't see
it's the same deal with marine like you
only see certain places Cersei sent mace
Tyrell on a mission to get more money
from the iron bank so I do think that
we'll see the iron bank again this
character that she meets here looks like
it's the kindly man from the books
although technically the first face that
the kindly man shows her is more of like
a like a skeleton with scraps of skin
hanging off of it
he even has like a worm crawling out of
his eye that Arya has to kiss it's like
her way of showing that she's not afraid
in the episode I think her standing up
to those street thugs kind of took the
place of that thematically and did
anyone else think that it was curious
that when she was saying her prayer
outside on the steps
she said the mountains name the whole
list is actually very long so we're
actually only hearing just like a small
part of it in the mountain yes who
wonders what he's gonna do with that
head probably just experimented on him
you know maybe harvested for stuff
because there's a bunch of mountain
related stuff in the books I want to
wait till we see more of what the show's
gonna do I just want to get too crazy
into spoilers so please use spoiler tags
if you want to talk about the mountain
or Robert strong from the books on to
number four pot and Brienne are like
every freaking chicken from season four
I feel kind of bad for Brianna it's like
every stark child that she runs into
just gives her the business and
to get out she did tell him the story of
the smoke baby which was kind of fun you
can't really tell if Littlefinger
believes her I think he just wants to
get rid of her she's like a wild card
that he just doesn't want to deal with
it was kind of hard to tell what Sansa
was thinking maybe she just feels like
Brienne reminds her of all the awful
things that have happened to her family
and she just doesn't want to deal with
it it's not that she likes Littlefinger
it's just that she's kind of grown
comfortable with their situation and
they're like they're weird alliance that
they've formed and she doesn't want to
deal with Brienne either as much as it
seems like Sansa trusts Littlefinger I
don't think that she does I think she's
like slowly wising up to the fact that
she can't trust anybody right now for
her I think it's more of a devil you
know situation she still has a lot to
learn though you know before she can
survive on her own without
Littlefinger's help it also didn't help
brands cause that she was wearing
Lannister gear with a Valyrian blade but
her speech was amazingly sincere Brienne
is one of those heartbreaking characters
that just like utterly sincere and
everything she does but just constantly
gets kicked in the mud I know everyone's
asking about Lady Stoneheart this season
I still don't expect to see her I think
when she and pod got separated and pod
ended up in the river
you could you could look at that as like
an Easter Egg for Lady Stoneheart just
because we're right around that time in
the books when she shows up you know I'm
not expecting it but that doesn't mean
that it won't happen you guys can let me
know whether you agree do you think the
Brienne is stupid for wanting to pursue
Sansa to try and help her even though
the Sansa wants to have nothing to do
with her should she just cut her losses
and try to go back and serve with Jaime
if she really wanted she could probably
be named to the Kingsguard by Tommen she
doesn't she have to do a little bit
convincing and Cersei might not be super
happy about it but it seems like
something that's never gonna happen like
total fanfic on to number three Cersei
and Jaime decided that Jamie is going to
go to Dorne to get Myrcella if you're
wondering who sent that message who sent
the threat it's probably ilaria Sand
she's the one that's trying to start a
war with the Lannisters they've changed
a whole lot about the sand snake so I
think a Laureus sand is Arianne Martell
from the books with a little bit of
Obara sand too we didn't see him in this
episode so I'm just gonna wait till next
week to talk about what the show is
doing with the sand snakes so she tells
Jaime that Michelle is being kept at the
water gardens the water gardens are
where Prince Doran Martell has been
hiding himself just just so his subjects
don't
how bad has gout has gotten he just
doesn't want them to see him as weak
it's so much fun seeing dr. Bashir
Martel I'm a big fan of Alexander siddig
he actually he said something really
interesting about his performance as
Doran Martell he said that he's basing a
lot of the way he speaks his accent on
what Pedro Pascal did in season four
it's just the inside the universe of the
show Pedro Pascal originated the Martell
characters so all the other actors that
are members of his family you know the
Martell family has to take cues from
that he's gonna be a lot of fun what I'm
really hoping is is that you know we see
some of this character in season five
and he becomes a much bigger character
in season six the same thing that they
did with the Laureus and areo Hotah is
gonna be a lot of fun too I would say
after Oberyn Martell vs. the mountain
like the next biggest fight that I would
like to see would be brawn versus area I
don't know things will go down that way
but if there's any two people in
Westeros that I'd like to see fight it
would be those two on to number two
Daenerys tries to figure out what to do
with the sons of the harpy
so they capture one but then one of her
freed slaves execute him and she's
forced to execute him in the name of
justice is this whole big thing about
her trying to be more of a diplomat
versus a tyrant like her father it's
funny that she doesn't know a lot about
her father she says Viserys told her
things but you know he probably didn't
tell her the whole truth the Mad King
lots of wildfire did not end well for
anyone Barristan pretty much narrates
Robert's rebellion for her
the rebellion didn't start so much
because of Lyanna stark being supposedly
kidnapped by Rhaegar Targaryen even
though I think that he didn't kidnap her
in the first place what happened is as
the Mad King killed a bunch of nobles
those noble families banded together and
started the rebellion Robert Baratheon
was just the point man he was just the
person everyone rallied behind so it
wasn't the entire kingdom going to war
over a woman being kidnapped it looks
kind of like Daenerys is facing the same
situation like these are gonna descend
to civil war inside Marine we're only in
episode two so definitely expect things
to escalate and isn't it funny how
Barristan call that wildfire and then we
see drogon at the end of the episode he
looks big enough to ride definitely big
enough to ride that would be a really
quick way to solve all of her problems
just roast all the people yelling at her
and finally my number one WTF moment
jaqen H'ghar reveals himself to arya
this is a really big departure from the
books that
finally man you know this person here
who jackin was masquerading as people
thought he might be jacking a gar but
technically jackin Hegar in the books is
like off on another mission doing
something else on the other side of the
world so I think we can assume that
they're cutting out pretty much all of
the Citadel plot in season 5 if you
don't know what I'm talking about
don't worry it doesn't matter for the
show Jack and nag are gonna teach her
the way of the warrior the way of the
faceless warrior I'd say generally of
all the running storylines right now
that I'm most excited about its Jaime
and Bronn headed to Dorne
yay fer lawless I'm so happy laws his
back that was such a funny scene with
Bronn and Arya learning to become a
faceless man this is a bonus you know we
have to address John Snow becoming Lord
Commander are you this should have been
like a top six moments but anyway Jon
Snow Lord Commander right out of the
books Samwell conspires with the other
brothers to elect him I loved how
maester aemon was the one that cast the
deciding vote and a lot of you were
disappointed that Jon didn't take
Stannis's deal to become a stark that
will come back around eventually I think
you know that it wasn't like a one-time
deal his sense of duty will continue to
be tested here's my big question for you
guys you know what was your favorite
moment from the episode and what do you
think it's gonna take for Jon Snow to
take Stannis's deal to legitimize him
and become Jon Stark
if Arya isn't going to be able to give
up her past life you know become no.1 as
Jack and implied do you think that the
same thing is gonna happen with Jon Snow
like they'll both end up choosing family
over duty I mean I would really love to
see that it'd be a very human choice to
make humans are flawed so as much as Jon
wants to uphold the ideals that he
believes in he's probably going to make
the emotional choice at a certain point
all in all great episode you know I know
a lot of people were disappointed in the
first episode just because it moved a
little slowly and they just spend so
much time setting stuff up but now I
feel like we're actually moving forward
we're moving all these plot lines
forward
just a reminder I'll announce the winner
of my giveaway in my Q&A tomorrow so be
sure to subscribe to get that if you
haven't already all you have to do the
end of the giveaways is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment nice and
simple I haven't decided what my bonus
video is gonna be for next week so feel
free to leave me any requests in the
comments
maybe something Dornish if we're gonna
see more of the Martel's hopefully we'll
see more of the Martel's next week so
why use wait for that Q&A to post you
can click here to learn more about the
faceless men of Braavos in the house of
black and white and you can click here
for my episode 1 video from last week
thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]